hello my name is Mel McKenzie and I'm a
I'm a volunteer for gowanda's AFC a
highlight for me would be making a South
Island New Zealand Academy when I was
younger and becoming a life member for
gold Wanderers last season was pretty
pretty awesome I enjoy volunteering
because of giving back to a pub that
I've been involved with for a long time
and given back to a sport that's been a
passion for mine for 32 years I love
volunteering and working with small Pig
small kids right up to adults and we're
always looking for helpers like any club
are struggling for numbers for for
helpers so if you want to get involved
we'd love to have you happy volunteer
week to all our Volunteers in our
community keep up the great work we love
your work and we hope to see more of you
guys around the Hyde Park at Gore
Wanderers